danke mal begeistert wären je nach hause
kommt herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video ich bin hier alleine mit dem
leon super anderes leon allein mit dem
leon im ruf vor zu später stunde gerade
ist nix geburtstagsgeschenke angekommen
ich hab schon so lange drauf gewartet
hatten und die liste art und weise zu
modifizieren aber sie werden kann müssen
wir beide super einsatz wären erstmal
zum sport und sogar zu machen damit
jeder denkt dass wir im sport sind und
da sind wir auch schon wieder im ofen
wurde und jetzt hoffentlich endlich mal
weggeht dankeschön und wo ich hätte mich
um revidiert und zwar durch eine drohne
gebraucht dann ganz könnte sogar zu
leeren und packen die man aus so dass
ich mein handy riesen würde auf jeden
fall erzählt einfach aus wie aus dem
teppich
man kann braucht keine richtige kleid
sonst nein
die kleine bühne ging hat weil nehmer
dass er weniger nach
hab ich gesagt dass es eigentlich liebes
geburtstagsgeschenk ist gut aber es gibt
noch was wenn sie die kasse aus es ist
jetzt so viel krasser aus ohne die sind
also gut jetzt wohne
ok also die drohne scheint eben wie ein
bisschen witzig zu sein weil sie immer
so ein bisschen weiß auch nicht wieso
ich denke nur noch oben und da geht
jeder kompletten verlust ist
so ich habe jetzt herausgefunden woran
ist in der lage und zwar war das
überhaupt nicht die schuld der drohne
sondern meine schulden denn man kann ich
jetzt wohne nämlich so komplett keinen
kalibrieren das ist echt krass
möglichkeit man hat das ganze habe ich
eben durch diese bedienungsanleitung
herausgefunden und was ich dann noch aus
gefunden habe ist und jetzt gucken wir
mal ganz kurz das gibt es immer was mit
160 grad überschläge da bin ich ja mal
richtig gespannt darauf wie das
funktionieren soll millionstes video ich
spiele mit dieser zone entwicklung dazu
gucken wie ich begeistert vision kit
wird diese aufnahme geht jetzt schon
seit einer halben stunde aber es wird
einfach nicht langweilig so jetzt gucken
wir mal
man kann sie einfach so pflücken und es
fliegt das ist so krass ist ja richtig
geil
aber was ich noch gesehen habe ist dass
man gemäss anscheinend 360° umdrehungen
machen kann und zwar noch mehr oder
weniger nein
die kanadier haben so schädlich na egal
ich glaube ich hätte akku ist leer aber
ich liebe das ist nicht leicht das jetzt
mal wieder auch und ich drauf wären wenn
der akku wieder voll es schaffen wie es
endlich mal 160 grad umdrehung zu
schaffen weil ich mir es nicht
vorstellen kann wie das automatisch
gehen wir mit zitronen
bis gleich so drohen jetzt wieder
aufgeladen und nicht übertreibe nicht es
ist der schick ich liebe das ist denn
gerade mit lehrern gesprochen und er
kaufte sich direkt auch schon an krone
und ein paar batterien damit ihr ein
bisschen länger hält man sich mehrere
batterien auf ja und wir machen coole
races gegeneinander bauen hier im ruf
folgen wie ein kasten parcours auf und
setzen dann mit unseren skills die wir
bis dahin hoffentlich haben und ich bin
viel zu aufgeregt aber ich habe es so
bock drauf ich habe sofort gemerkt dass
direkt ich finde es aber sogar diese
zeige ich nicht kaputt man kann einfach
unterschrieben so gut ich hatte noch nie
so ein helikopter als kind hatte er
sowas und diese drohne ist für euch
total langweilig aber ich bin die so
kraus negativ fallen deswegen kostet 20
euro das kann alles ja nicht alles hat
keine kamera so aber es funktioniert im
prinzip wie so eine echte krasselt runde
wir haben nirgendwo okay die haben wir
nicht hier nahm er eine krasse drohne
die auch filmen kann aber zuvor eine
steuerung her ist die echte man kann
damit auch über gut üben und vor allem
was ist alle wichtigste ist es macht
auch spaß und während die batterie
gerade aufgenommen hat habe ich mich ein
bisschen schlau gemacht und habe dieses
handbuch gelesen denn auch wenn ich am
anfang gesagt habe ich lese handbuch
nicht lohnt sich es hier wirklich dieses
handbuch zu lesen weil es macht einfach
viel mehr spaß wenn man die ganzen
funktionen kennt und ich habe schon
wieder viel zu viel auf jeden fall zeige
ich euch jetzt den 360 grad blick jetzt
hochdruckzone einem experten kopf und wo
ich liebe das ist denkt man kann fliegen
damit man salz kann ich leben aber es
ist fast genauso cool auf jeden fall
träume ich davon betriebe und leon und
vielleicht mit einer leuten aus dem ufo
so rennen zu fahren mit diesen dingen
und coole kunststücke zu machen und
welche par kurs zu beschreiten und gerät
viel zu schnell ich weiß ich das total
oft in einem kommentar herr thomas
wredes voll schnell in den videos ich
weiß aber jetzt bin ich halt einfach
richtig aufgeregt und habe hilfe
praktisch auszuprobieren und wie gesagt
deswegen habe ich jetzt mir jetzt direkt
nochmal ne zweifel davon gekauft für
mich weil wir so viel wie und hat mir
zudem noch fünf akkus gekauft damit man
auch wirklich immer belegen kann ich hab
euch noch mal den link in die
beschreibung gepackt falls ihr das
möchte weil ich finde dieses ding so
geil und es kostet nur 20 euro das wäre
jetzt vielleicht weihnachten irgendwie
etwas cooles braucht eure geschwister
irgendwelche freunde oder wenn ja was
selbst bock drauf habe dann ohne scheiß
ich kann es nur empfehlen es ist echt
richtig geil und ich reden viel zu viel
ich denke jetzt kommen wir langsam es ja
essen so leute wir haben jetzt lecker
gegessen und jetzt sage ich mal dem
leonhard kurz denkt man dem leonce
brötchen es schwer
hab ich gesagt das ist jetzt mal gut
geht
und sagt hey museen ich hoffe mal dass
auch der kamera auch gut erkannt dann
mach das nochmal verfällt
wir wollen also meinem schlitten willst
dann musst du die rechte schulter aus
dass die hinten drücken und dann nachdem
in allerdings bitten möchte stehen hier
mit links dann rechts schon nach vorn
finden
okay das ich muss meinen ersten hebel
und dann die tasse gleich der erste
klasse und daneben das tram peter ist in
diesem modus drehen und dann noch auf
letten muss nochmal diese klasse könnten
ja nochmal was eigentlich straße
gedrückt und die fassung
ich glaube der akku selbst einfach mehr
tote gesehen alles perfekt befolgt nach
schaden
dank jetzt auch nicht ob wir gerade
aufnahme und jetzt wegen etwas testen
aber ich glaube das ist wir können sogar
eine crazy skate ehemals der
straßenstrecke oder was nein das würde
lang lang ist's her ich kann jetzt
einmal auf diesem tisch fans würden sagt
weise
leicht zu verwalten scheint schon
gesellschaft würde man kommt rein auf
jeden fall die steuerung auf jeden fall
gibt es jetzt nämlich an die nächste
sagen jetzt haben wir ewig damit
zugebracht das ist zu fliegen was echt
geil war auf jeden fall soll das ja
geschenkt
auf jeden fall war es ein geschenk für
regel seien und dass man sollte etwas
persönlicher gestaltet werden und
deswegen dass ich nicht noch was drauf
und darija kurz davor ist dort zu
beerdigen wollte ich ihnen so als
andenken quasi mit photoshop so ein
kleines bild passen wo quasi er und dann
wird auch schon im flieger sitzt sitzen
bei der mit kohle piloten pillen und die
dann auf diesen ring sitzen und man kann
nie wie die beide durch die gegensteuern
und quasi noch einmal ein letztes mal
mit seinem privatjet um diesen ist
gleichwohl haben wir entschädigen
ausflugs kommt es schon müssen ab ja
solar jetzt ist es ein zweites geben
unfassbar cool seit 2006 panahi bislang
darauf wurde
guck doch wann immer ein zu steuern
also man muss dazu sagen
dieser gott ist schon indikatoren
ausgemacht es gibt übrigens auch merken
das tier nach oben kommen ja noch was ja
so was wie ausgeprägt aber wie machen
wir das die halt auf einer höhe bleibt
das ist schwer aber nur ein bisschen
zugenommen
das ist dann eben das ist erstens
hinterher
was dass sie alles was macht ihr einfach
die irgendjemand auf das letzte mal
vielleicht normalverbraucher klippel der
platin enthalten
das ist schon ein alter ich wollte schon
immer dafür gebühren oder voll geil
gegen den kopf fliegen kann wäre wohl du
du hast dann auch geköpft
was kann ich dann mit der drohne immer
gegen den kopf fliegen ist die kaffee
ich nehme jedes über marie teuer
nee was nicht wie es echt mega günstig
wird also ich bin zu krass von diesen
dingen überzeugt würdest du deinen penis
da rein halten ich würde das auf jeden
fall tun aber auch nicht die drohne
ich musste meinen beruf zeigen sich
eigentlich drin und dann wissen richtig
augen verlieren wollte die zeitung war
50 je nach hause kommt vielen dank fürs
zu sehen dafür dass sie ihm geschenkt
egal
das was von diesem wir wissen extra
nachdrücklich
ja